bonjour chers télénautes bonjour chers
et loi encore une émission de diagonale
dalles sont consacrés aux pions c'est ce
sont des fins de parties qui apparemment
semble simple mais il faut les connaître
sur le bout des doigts
alors aujourd'hui vas tu nous montres et
oui alors la dernière fois nous avons vu
les finales d'options simple
c'est-à-dire wépion contre eurois est-ce
que c'est gagnant est ce que c'est nul
il y avait diverses cas différents cas
donc là vous avez bien sûr l'occasion de
revenir voir cette première étape des
finales d'options dans les différents
diagonale les finales donc un pion
suffit aurais tu rencontreras et ce
gagnant à ce nul vous pouvez tout savoir
en revenant dans les différer maintenant
plus compliqué c'est dire qu'on va
s'attaquer au final option complexe avec
plusieurs clubs d'accord alors là je
vous avais tu va nous montrer une arme
terrible en finale de pioncer le pion
passé éloignés voilà j'en chante à
s'éloigner il est très fort pourquoi
hein parce que c'est un pion passé alors
qu'ils ont passé c'est à dire qu'il n'ya
plus d'opposants devant lui et donc le
chemin est tout tracé il n'a plus qu'a
avancé et il n'a pas de pions adverse
sur son passage la seule chose qui peut
donc arrêter un tueur passé en finale
deux pions c'est le roi alors maintenant
j'en passe et éloigné c'est mieux
pourquoi l1 pour une raison très simple
c'est que le pion fait simplement
diversion c'est à dire que il est loin
et c'est forcément le roi qui va venir
le chercher
et pendant ce temps là donc quand le roi
la dé prendre des temps et des temps
pour aller chercher le pion qui sera
placée et éloigner notre droit à nous
lui il va pouvoir se ruer dans les
brancards est allé manger tous les pions
adverse de l'autre côté bon alors je
crois que déjà il ya la position de base
qu'il faut connaître un on va là on va
la regarder
vous avez deux rois sur l'échiquier qui
sont en opposition d'un côté de
l'échiquier 1 sur les cases à 2 à 4 et
vous avez un pion de l'autre côté le
champion a shark et comment il faut
faire ici alors nous avions déjà vu
cette position dans le temps la leçon
précédente
effectivement il ya un pion passé là qui
est éloigné le pion est passé il n'a pas
d'opposants il est également éloigné
puisqu'il est très loin des rois alors
c'est au noir de jouer il joue comme
premier coup un rop et 5 très logique
donc on essaye de courir vers le pion
pour l'empêcher d'aller à dame
leroy court vers le pion met donc le
pion avance bien entendu deux cas on
rappelle que le plus fort peu avant ces
deux cases même à la fin de la partie
quand il est sur sa case d'années parce
quand il est sur la case départ le pion
à vence est là donc on s'aperçoit on va
refaire le carré du pion c'est ce qu'on
avait expliqué la dernière fois c'est à
dire qu'on forme une sorte de carré on
voit là vous voyez votre arsenal
ensuite à partir de là vous remonter
jusqu'à la hauteur du pion et là nous
avons le carré c'est à dire que si le
roi noir
enfin le roi et demi au pays arrivent à
se mettre dans ces cases verte dans ce
réseau de case verte
eh bien il va stopper le pion il va
l'arrêter il va même le manger d'accord
d'accord pour tirer le carré on prend la
diagonale qui part du pion un barde du
pion et ensuite est en forme le car est
donc ici on s'aperçoit très vite que le
roi n'est pas dedans donc forcément le
pion va aller tout seul adam
c'est un exemple option étant passé
personne ne l'arrêta par le roi le roi
n'étant pas dans le carré il est donc
trop loin mais est on s'aperçoit que et
fait valoir nicolas ils ont clairement
fait en fait dames ont fait promotion
dame promotionnelle encore une fois on a
le choix on a tort de choisir une dame
un cavalier un fou une tour mais on
prend évidemment la dame puisque après
on a une finale technique roi et dames
contre roye qu'on a déjà vu oui et que
donc je vous répète c'est important que
vous pouvez retrouver dans différé sur
canal web sur diagonale un vous cliquez
vous avez un problème technique et vous
revoyez ces finales il faut les
connaître tous les joueurs n'y a pas
besoin d'être grand maître dit m tous
les joueurs de compétition connaît ça
par coeur pour aider un contre roy c'est
effectivement la finale de base donc ici
une fois que vous avez fait dame
vous savez matez donc s'est terminé
alors on revoit une dernière fois cette
position de départ on voit dans cette
position-là l'option blanc h2 qui est
ici vers il est passé il est éloigné et
donc il suffit tout seul à gagner la
partie
donc on va maintenant passer un deuxième
exemple mais plus complexe
c'est simple à cet exemple là était
simple on comprend qu'il faut le pion
doit aller foncé vers la dame alors là
effectivement c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'il ya des pions en
plus et ils sont pas là que pour décorer
voilà
il y a donc une grosse différence il ya
ça alors rappelons nous on l'a vu dans
la leçon de la dernière fois sur le
thème un pion suffit que cette formation
là si on enlève les pions qui sont verts
c'est à dire si on laisse que les pièces
rouges
cette position est nul c'est le fameux
pions h pas le pion qui est donc sur le
côté ne gagne pratiquement jamais
spécialement quand le roi et demi est
proche
donc là ça serait tout simplement nul
s'il n'y avait pas ces pions en verre de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier
voilà et c'est là justement que l'on
passé éloigné veut faire sa diversion
alors la méthode est là on va être
didactique la méthode c'est de d'abord
prendre le position rendirent un nîmois
je sais qu'il va revenir là dessus parce
que c'est fondamental mais un petit mot
sur l'opposition
un petit mot sur une position c'est donc
les fameux roi on est souvent en face
durant et demi voilà et on gagne du
terrain puisqu'il est obligé de faire
des concessions
alors ici le premier coup blanc et un
roi f4 voilà on prend l'opposition
effectivement on se met face au roi et
demi l'idée dans cette finale c'est très
simple c'est que là le roi noir
maintenant et dans un devant et curieux
dilemme est ce qu'il faut aller prendre
l'option blanc qui est en h4 le pion
blanquier tout seul si way ou est ce
qu'il faut aller défendre son pion ici
en b 6 le roi ne sais pas trop il va pas
pouvoir faire le et ne pourra pas faire
les deux voilà c'est là la clé de
l'énigme donc considérons dans un
premier temps qu'il va essayer de manger
le pion blanc qu'il est alain à les
arrêter plus blanc alors là le côté
blanc c'est très simple le pion là peut
être sacrifié ouais sacrifier tout
simplement il fait une diversion et nous
avec notre roi on fonce de l'autre côté
donc là on prend à contre-pied le roi
noir vient manger le pion mais là on
s'aperçoit qu'il est quand même très
très en retard il est sérieusement en
retard puisque nous on continue notre
marche vers les pions il revient il
essaie de revenir tout au moins on prend
le premier pion il revient encore et on
prend encore action et là c'est une
finale très très simple à gagner
pourquoi et bien la méthode la plus
simple pour nier cette finale on fait
abstraction du plan b 3 on en a pas
besoin
on amène le roi là il contrôle déjà ces
trois cases là et on va avancer notre
pions match bon là c'est gagné
et ce alors c'est bon je crois que ton
image de contre-pied c'est exactement
comme au foot au tennis at on fait
croire qu'on va d'un côté le pion de
plus le pion pas s'éloigner oblige le
roi d'aller dans un côté on passe de
l'autre
oui on a un petit coup de rein il n'y a
rien à faire on insiste là-dessus c'est
vraiment très important et si le pion
pas s'éloigner va obliger le roi noir 2
de s'occuper de lui parce que c'est une
malle à saint leu ni vous avez disait
que le pion un pion passé c'était un
assassin un assassin potentiel tiac les
foules
il faut essayer de le tenir en respect
le problème c'est que s'il tient en
respect il peut pas les défendre les
pauvres piot donc voyons une deuxième
possibilité pour les noirs c'est la
cohue y aller doucement dans cette
position une nouvelle possibilité c'est
dire qu'il dit je ne vais pas arrêter le
jeu ne bouge pas je vais aller défendre
les biens c'est un foot joue comme ça
possibilité voilà il se dit je vais
aller défendre les pions alors dans ce
cas là il suffit de pousser un peu plus
la diversion voilà on avance notre pions
pourquoi pas donc là par contre il peut
pas sortir du carré en revoyant le carré
encore une fois voilà le carré étant là
il est obligé la salade un sinon le
campath adam
voilà donc le roi doit rester donc il
peut pas aller sur la case une case
piégé ici serait la case des six donc le
ballet dessus donc il reviendrait
logiquement à 26
et là on repart voilà tout simplement là
ils essayent de rester encore ils
essaient il a un finalement le centre
j'ai tout essayé de rester là mais là on
continuerait on verrait la diversion
alors là le cari serait du lien qu'il
essayait de rentrer car elle il faut
qu'ils rentrent dans le carré c'est à
dire qu'il reviendrait par exemple sur
lesquels là et là il est obligé de
lâcher les cases et là ils lâchent la
faire voilà on va les manger ces
documents voilà donc ça c'est revenons
sur la pression de départ une position
très simple les blancs ont un pion hcap
qui est champion passé éloignés
on dira jamais assez c'est exactement la
définition de ces options de l'autre
côté il ya des pions qui se tiennent en
vis-à-vis et là tout simplement ont fait
diversion
on va d'un côté avec le roi attaque
élections et demi de l'autre côté on
avance notre passé est tout simplement
ça suffit pour gagner donc alors je
reviens aussi pour être plus générale
c'est un pion tu nous l'as dit tu nous
le redis un pion souffre souvent suffit
pour gagner
bon il ya quelques cas nul mais alors
quand il ya deux pions d'avancé a gagné
2 95%
1 oui là qu'est ce que c'est on l'a vu
c'est vous inquiétez pas tout simplement
aller doucement regarder quand même que
ces finales qui sont simples demandes de
la méthode c'est à dire qu'il faut quand
même y aller doucement bien faire
prenez-vous souffler un peu floue
souffler on a vu dans le stress info
savoir qu'aussi camps en compétition
dans le stress parfois ça se passe tous
au bout de trois quatre heures de jeu 5
heures de jeu on peut se fatiguer donc
il faut aller doucement vous savez que
là vous êtes gagnant donc vous prenez
votre temps oui oui et non c'est clair
en tout cas dans une finale option il
faut pas jouer au coup par coup
ça c'est un grand principe élaborer
votre plan travailler tranquillement vos
stratégies dites vous qu'il ya un pion
passé qui va aller là le roi qui valait
de l'autre côté tout ça très calmement
une fois qu'on a trouvé le plan le plan
de gains qui est ici une diversion bête
et méchant c'est à dire de menace à la
fois il ne peut pas parler d'eux une
fois qu'on a bien trouvé ce plan est
bien là on commence à jouer les coups on
commence à se concentrer sur les coûts
donc là je pense que cet exemple est
assez clair vous l'aurez un jour vous
aurez peut-être pas exactement cette
position mais vous allez retrouver ça il
faut savoir que ça arrive souvent vous
avez bien joué une partie vous avez un
pion avance fond faire quelque chose ici
ici voilà un curieux dilemme si les
pions côté gauche de l'échiquier n'était
pas là ça serait complètement nul le
fait est qu'ils sont là et donc nous
permet de faire cette diversion et de
gagner la partie
alors un petit troisième exemple alors
oui quand
on est en difficulté un cerf quand on a
vu alors là ça devient déjà un peu plus
compliqué alors là ça devenait un peu
atypique même je dirais un peu atypique
c'est à dire que d'abord eloi a voulu
absolument se mais c'est bien c'est bien
d'abord on à égalité matérielle comptons
le matériel
il faut toujours dire ça aux échecs ça
va vous sembler un petit peu fastidieux
mais après ça devient presque un réflexe
on compte toujours le matériel ici vous
avez deux pions blancs contre deux pions
noirs donc a priori il ya une relative
égalité vous pouvez le savoir mais mais
il ya une grosse différence
enfin chaque camp adoption passé les
noirs ont d'options passé ici passent et
toujours dans le sens où il ya pas de
pions blancs pour les arrêter et les
blancs ont d'options passé ici donc on
va me dire quelle est la différence
et bien tout simplement les tournois
rinne son groupe et alors que les pions
blancs sont splitter splitté ou disons
éloignés les uns des autres
donc tout ça va entraîner un
oui mais moi je là je vais t'en ben
était un petit peu c'est à dire que
souvent et
dans le début de partie dans le mieux
parti on dit vaut mieux groupe et ses
pions c'est mieux quand de psion sont
liés et c'est donc en finale c'est pas
vrai alors voilà j'ai donc là je laisse
des questions en stratégie générale
oui une explication simple c'est que
vous voyez que les options qui sont là
se défendre mutuellement et ça c'est une
bonne chose
c'est à dire qu'il suffit de défendre
celui qui est là le tube et 4 il y en a
qu'un seul à défendre puisque lui-même
défend l'autre ça c'est l'avantagé des
pions groupe et les plus éloignés
effectivement ne se défendent pas entre
eux voilà alors qu'est ce qui se passe
en milieu de jeu il ya des pièces qui
ont des portées très longue qui vont
très vite d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier donc là pour eux les pions
passé douaniers c'est de la rigolade
c'est à dire qu'ils vont très très vite
d'un bout à l'autre de l'échiquier
donc ya pas de problème ils arrêtent le
pion sur la case de promotion où ils
veulent donc la priorité à la défense il
faut défendre ses pions en revanche
quand il n'ya plus clairoix qui est une
pièce quand même assez lente puisque
elle se déplace que d'une case à la fois
là la priorité est à la diversification
d'accord donc les deux options là ne
font pas une menace vraiment diversifié
mais elle n'arrive pas à dominer
icaunaise qui contrôle le roi semble
dominer voilà pour le roi sans le
dominer c'est exactement ça sert que le
roi là ne peut pas prendre ce pion alors
pourquoi puisque à ce moment-là il
sortirait du carré de l'autre pions le
car est le pion à 3 d'accord qui est ici
donc si droit se met sur la case rouge
qui est toujours donc visons le niqab
piégé d'accord à ce moment là le pion
irait adam d'ailleurs on peut on peut
peut-être le montrer voilà ouais donc
nombreux à prendre qui ont
malheureusement assez ça d'accord
malheureusement le plus en avance à la
main dans le cul avancées y vas y ramène
le moins d'un an mais sa graine alors ça
ça fait rien c'est ce que la dame est
une pièce à longue portée en cas comment
on fait l'arrêt manger tout ce qu'il
faut manger tous les pions il faut
commencer par manger moment je les
violons on se met dans notre finale
thématique moi c'est qu'on connaît bien
on a déjà vu on rails d'un contrat droit
et ont maintenant donc dans cette
position là effectivement les blancs ne
peuvent pas apprendre le piano ne
peuvent pas progresser de ce côté-là
échiquier alors maintenant quand tu es
noir qu'est ce qui se passe puisque la
l'échiquier vraiment séparé anglais
l'europe on ne peut pas aller du côté
drôle de chiqué et inversement
qu'est ce qui se passe on adoption passé
il va falloir en avance et enfin les
avancées de l'accord si on ne voit pas
d'un bon ne gagnera pas on va donc là
alors une proposition c'est le coup h5
donc toi tu donnes le plus éloigné un
pur ap ap ap ap ap le maître loin loin
très loin le roi noir d'éloigner le roi
noir au maximum très logiquement le roi
noir vient angers 5
il veut essayer de l'arrêter de le
manger mais y'a d'la la menace est
sérieuse menaçait de prendre l'option
d'accord malheureusement il y a le
deuxième pont la deuxième diversion qui
montante des 5 km sur 7 15 la sortie il
ya un chasseur mais il ya deux lapins
c'est ça il ya deux lapins la veille
donc là on reforme le carré de ce pion
et on voit tout de suite que le pion h5
il est en dehors du cac a cédé à que si
maintenant le roi noir pointent pions
l'autre est inarrêtable
et voilà le document on peut le regarder
ouais 3.5 est une possibilité il y
aurait des six
voilà le roi mon temps j'ai six des sept
ans voit bien que c'est trop tard donc
c'est pas possible puisque a pas
d'enfant à vii ont fait dames et
maintenant ça devient une partie de
plaisir la dame va ramasser les
d'options noir et on mate d'accord ça
bon je pense qu'on l'a bien saisi donc
des cinq donc revoyons ouais on a
commencé par jouer h5
ouais le roi est venu verse option car
on avance le deuxième est donc là alors
là le roi
alors essayé d'imprimer entre deux feux
à prendre le pion à chaque don qu'il
essaye de contrôler et depuis on est ce
que c'est possible alors il vient sur la
case f5 f5 dix mois entre les deux il
supporte le guardian but il est vrai
livre via des prêts donc on en choisit
un avancé puisque l'aca ne change plus
rien à coeur on prend qui ont des six
ont la bosse d'accord ça aurait été
pareil avec l'option qu'il faut c'est en
été c'est le seul à mettre entre les
cartels et là c'est plutôt années voilà
c'est un essai ravaillac la pauvre à
serra va ça va c'est oui c'est ça c'est
ravaillac qu'ils ont que ces faits car
tous les ans mais ses 110 je pense à lui
parce que c'est l'anniversaire de sa
mort ravaillac bien voilà mon passé
cette précision historique
voilà nous pouvons voir que là une fois
de plus même même topo
on attaque le pion donc les blancs vont
de l'autre côté on revoit le carré de
soutien il est ici on peut on peut faire
une comparaison avec le foot c'est
cesser le travail sur les ailes c'était
souvent aux il faut des ailiers on va
sur les ailes pour pour élargir le jeu
et finalement élargir la défense
exactement ce qui se passe
oui tu ne cours pas raison comme et
l'autre mais on peut aussi voir ça comme
un contrepied au tennis contrepied au
tennis et qu'il est en congé
finalement un peu pâle et tous les côtés
donc ici c'est exactement ce qui se
passe c'est à dire que le roi vient
aussi s'attaquer le pion on avance
le mna deuxième me narrait il continue à
tenter de garder contrôle
oui mais là suffit d'en avancer un leroy
obligé de revenir gare ici et là
maintenant on prend un vrai plaisir on
avance l'autre et ça va être très très
simple alignés donc là on reprend un peu
cet exemple on est à égalité matérielle
de pions liée contre deux pions pas
s'éloigner
et là ils peuvent en finale est plus
fort parce que effectivement comme ils
sont éloignés ils sont éloignés du roi
finalement aussi ils vont éloigner le
roi et le roi va pas pouvoir les arrêter
en même temps donc sachez faux faux faux
que vous quand vous allez sur sur
diagonale
vous prenez votre temps vous revoyez ces
exemples ils vont vous servir tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps non mais ça ça paraît un peu
fastidieux et vous verrez petit à petit
qu'on va vous trouver des exemples où il
ya des superbes combinaisons place que
l'on vous montre la base mais tout
revient à ça oui c'est à dire que
finalement ce qui ce que vous voyez là
est assez simple à comprendre vous
l'aurez compris très vite
par contre ce qui est plus dur c'est de
l'intégrer complètement à sa façon de
penser aux échecs
ce qui fait que quand on commence une
combinaison complexe et aboutit
justement à ce genre d'opposition on les
évalue immédiatement et on sait si ça
gagne aussi c'est nul ce qui évite
d'avoir à calculer c'est en partie ce
qui ce commencerait à être vraiment
vraiment lourd en calcul donc là
maintenant ça va être intuitive vous
voyez finale de pions tuons pas
s'éloigner c'est bon pourquoi alors
c'est là qu'on va peut-être arriver à
notre exemple plus compliqué bah c'est
aller à qu'on peut si on sait ça on va
essayer de créer un pion pas s'éloigner
voilà voilà maintenant on va revient un
peu avant voyez vous c'est aux échecs
finalement ça c'est là où ça sert de
connaître les fin parce qu'on sait que
sega on sait que ça gagne pas redondant
sexuelle
cette saga c'est que ce gâchis voilà
donc nous arrivons dans une finale de
pions non c'est de fait ça va de plus en
plus compliqué c'est à dire qu'avant
c'était un contre 0 ensuite trois contre
deux
deux contre deux essais de phase i 3
contre 3 il ya toujours de plus en plus
d'options
alors ici voilà une position qui a l'air
a priori nul puisque il ya deux rois et
trois pions pour pour chaque camp on se
demande presque qui est mieux dans cette
position alors réponse
premièrement les blancs ont un avantage
l'espace et ça c'est important
puisqu'ils sont des pions qui sont plus
avancés avec ces deux jours là sont plus
avancés que les d'options noir pourquoi
c'est important des plus avancés c'est
simplement parce qu'on est plus près de
la case de promotion donc dans très
important à regarder on reprend des
petits trucs parce que chien il faut pas
faire travailler votre mémoire c'est on
regarde l'espace si on a un peu plus
d'espacé que l'autre c'est souvent un
peu mieux la position des rois un
laurent l'a vu un an tous nos exemples
le roi est une pièce maîtresse pendant
toute la partie mais très importante en
fin de partie puisque souvent justement
là ils risquent plus d'être matés donc
il peut il fait quelque chose
1 mais ça c'est une précision importante
qu'on aimait ma fenêtre encore mais
c'est effectivement le roi devient une
pièce forte en finale déjà en finale
d'options particulièrement déjà parce
que c'est la seule pièce passe donc pas
ce qu'il peut revenir en arrière et
surtout parce qu'il ne se fait pas mater
en tout cas c'est des cas extrêmement
rares endroits au final l'option moi
j'ai on peut peut-être aussi
on a du temps la wii est loi on a eu le
temps il yad'excellents bouquin sur les
finales j'en connais quelques-uns vous
avez le bouquin de samuel chére chef qui
sait pas si c'est de chercher si je suis
sur chérie celle ci s'est paré chef qui
sait chercher chez les chefs qui voyez
et qui parle réellement de ça avec des
exemples de finale
de passage en finale et surtout toujours
une instit je me souviens ils insistent
toujours sur l'activité du roi en finale
sinon vous avez le caire s le caire est
ce qu est un excellent bouquin ou le ou
le pac man oui alors le querrey s'est un
petit peu plus technique que tel mais je
dirais connaît en fait voyez vous avez
plusieurs types de livres pour les
finales donc ça on va faire une petite
précision biographique
oui et non parce que c'est important
parce que ça ça se travaille oui donc
vous avez un le celui que vous voulez
voir prendre de l'eau qui reste pour
commencer oui je crois il y étudie les
finales plus mathématiquement je dirais
c'est à dire c'est les finales de tours
où tout est forcé où il ya beaucoup de
ces plutôt calculatoire donc plus
technique évidemment la plus fertile où
ils sont le plus fort c'est ce que tu es
bien oui tout à fait alors que l'autre
le donc le fameux chercher ce qui est
qui s'appelle master in the game
voilà lui il est beaucoup plus
tranquille beaucoup plus décontracté il
vous dit simplement ou mettre vos pièces
quoi faire ce qu'il faut se presser
comment est-ce qu'on va gagner les
finales en général ils étudient les
finales complexe avec des pièces
une heure c'est un final de fouler
finale de cavaliers alors que carey
c'est plutôt et finale deux tours qui
sont plus mathématique d'accord donc il
ya deux types de livres évidemment pour
commencer pour commencer à tirer à
s'imprégner de l'esprit des finales il
vaut mieux commencer par les finales
philosophie appelons les comme ça celle
où il faut raisonner d'une façon plus
tranquille c'est à dire se dire mon fou
serait mieux ici mon cavalier serait
mieux là plutôt que ceux d'hier les vous
faire ça ça ça ça et ça et s'efforcer et
je vais gagner comme ça c'est peut-être
la bonne méthode capable en qu'elle
faisait comme ça et bien si kabze
qu'elle faisait il ya effectivement un
bouquin extraordinaire on va parler de
capa blanca qui lui croyaient
véritablement à l'apprentissage du jeu
d'échecs par les finales ces principes
fondamentaux de josé raul capable en cas
on vous le rappelle c'est le le champion
des années 1900 1920 et c'était un
joueur qui était connu pour avoir une
science des finales c'était un joueur
esthétique et il croyait beaucoup au
final alors on va revenir à cet exemple
revenons-en à ce dont ce dernier exemple
de la leçon sur les l'option pas
s'éloigner
que se passe-t-il inégalités matérielles
mais ici les blancs est un gros avantage
c'est que bon donc chacun un pion passer
l'option de l'an passé est ici alors que
l'option noir est ici donc l'option
blanc en fait est éloigné il ya gagné
comparé au cuir noir qui est plus
centrale et ça change tout ça change
vraiment ou non mais l'idée dans un
premier temps ces deux créations passées
ne le vraiment le mettre en valeur le
mettre en avant expliquait qu'il est là
on joue le coup à 4 à 5
donc là en craie et en menace bien aux
menaces tout simplement d'avancé une
fois de plus ça aide à penser encore et
encore mon menace de passer adam donc il
faut faire quelque chose là il faut
nécessairement nécessairement réagir
plusieurs possibilités y aurait roissy
ce qui est possible il y aurait plus on
prend lyon on va commencer par faire
préemption qui le plus simple là il faut
reprendre évidemment on reprend un
arpent toujours finale de samedi
s'il dorfman en finale il n'y a pas de
sacrifice d'options ça apparaît sa part
être un bon principe puisque juste plus
d'initiatives il ya beaucoup de la
palissade aux échecs mais qui font une
autre peu tarte à covè on n'a jamais
gagné une partie en abandonnant manqué
qui sont beaucoup moins idiote qu'elles
sont non l'aéroport à bord donc ici le
roi vient chercher pions ça paraît
logique
et maintenant on voit que le roi est
très bien placé ici on n'a pas envie
d'amener notre nom en pâture au roi ce
serait une faute
d'ailleurs nous pouvons regarder ce coup
à cinq à six qui est une fausse barbe
donc puisque après 3 b 6 3 des 5 reprend
rossé 6 on ne sait pas trop mais à
priori à priori à priori je n'ai pas d'à
priori je pense que ça va peut-être
gagner quand même donc les
revendications de ce que j'ai dit c'est
un peu plus accros banaliser un grand
bâtisseur c'est vachement autant prêt et
c'est effectivement pas une c'est pas
une bonne méthode ce n'est pas une
méthode
en fait tout simplement donc revoyons
dans cette position là plutôt que
d'avancer leurs pions tout de suite
alors qu'ils seraient mangés par le roi
noir c'est une bonne méthode jouer un
coup droit les couleurs roi ne
changerait souvent sont des coûts de
repos permettre de jouer les coups de
pions de toute façon pendant toute la
partie sans peut vraiment donner une
règle ce sont des coûts compromettant
pas forcément mauvais mais
compromettants oui voilà
oui c est aussi dorfman on va imiter dès
le coup de pions agit beaucoup plus la
structure de la partie
et voilà on en sort on se moque de lui
mon fond l'aiment bien parce qu'en plus
il a quand même beaucoup aidé les échecs
français en dehors en dispensant des
cours
badji ras du débutant au grand maître
c'est tout à fait vrai alors l'idée de
ce coup donc un roi henri iv c'est que
ça donne le trait au noir donc ça c'est
une sorte de mini zoug comme on appelle
ça c'est exemple à la salle un terme
compliqué quand même exemple c'est bien
de l'allemand je ne sais pas ce que je
sais moi connaissance mais pas là ça
veut dire la traduction littérale c'est
très fort c'était à cause échec on leur
dit allez les règles et c'est important
on a pas le droit de passer au bridge on
passe dans beaucoup de gens passent aux
échecs on est obligé de jouer comme au
jeu de dames d'ailleurs et parfois c'est
souvent un avantage le fait de jouer
mais en finale ça peut être un
désavantage donc ici on dit ou noir
jouer parce qu'il vous avait pas
beaucoup de coups et vous allez tu es
obligé de vous affaiblir votre avis là
d'éléments font faire une concession ici
puisqu'ils sont obligés de sedan levé le
roi de cette case
ils ne peuvent pas jouer lyon puisque
leurs pions sont bloqués son pied droit
et la 4c 6 sur laquelle il se trouvait
était la plus forte la meilleure nos
questions que j'ai de partir par exemple
en 17
maintenant évidemment on gagne du
terrain on joue roi b5
alors là les noirs n'ont pas trop le
choix dans cette position et 6 avancent
leurs pions ils vont se faire manger il
faut qu'ils bougent le roi et maintenant
on y va à roissy 6 on va commencer à
ramasser sion deux possibilités soit les
noirs contre-attaqué montant à 6 ce
qu'on va voir maintenant on vire à la
2ème plus tard là on prend le pion il
prend nos pions et maintenant même un
peu la même méthode mais tout à l'heure
ça qu'on a éloigné le roi l'avantagé
d'avoir un qui ont passé le agnès excès
éloigne le roi adverse qui doit faire
attention et maintenant on va foncer bas
pour manger ce pion voilà on va on va
prendre le dernier pion très vite vous
voyez il ya rien à faire on l'a mangé et
regarder valiant quand quelques coups
techniques il faut une loi que tu les
expliquer un petit peu parce que
maintenant c'est difficile aux échecs
info jamais - redit ses résultats il
faut jamais croire très facile a donc
cette finale là on l'a déjà vu dans la
leçon de la dernière fois la leçon de
vendredi
lundi dernier après roy f7 par exemple
ici il suffit d'avancer le pion et ça va
gagné très facilement puisque après
roger 6 on prend l'opposition prend
l'opposition donc là c'est vraiment un
rappel pour cette finale rouages suite
on rêve c'est de toute façon ils
devaient choisir son côté on aller de
l'autre
maintenant c'est fini puisque on
contrôle les trois cases d'avancé du
pion il ya plus qu à l'avancé donc tout
simplement une fois qu'on a pris pioncer
roi étions contre pions royan contre roy
on sait faire il y avait une autre
possibilité dans cette position là
dedans c'était avant d'ailleurs c'est la
position ici roy cette race et 6 on
aurait pu se dire avec les noirs ah bah
tiens je vais défendre mon pions je vais
jouer roi ici et alors là tout simple
grand on avance notre pions et ça ne va
pas changer grand chose
ouais puisque la sylvie ans s'est vite
et bien on va pousser notions il aura
plus de coups on va aller à dame
il vient donc en race est très
logiquement c'est la même position alors
qu'est ce qui se passe on va faire une
petite analyse comme de ce qui se passe
c'est que les blancs avaient un pion
passé sur la colonne à et les noirs sont
la colonne ces mémos finale dans toutes
les variantes le roi noir a été mangé le
pion sur la colonne a alors que le roi
blanc a été le manger sur la colonne ces
mets donc le roi blanc se retrouvent
mieux placé voilà puisque justement les
plus proches du clan ennemi et c'est
toujours pour ça que ça gagne dans cette
finale
alors on pour voir la position de départ
donc on reprend à cette fois didactique
ici égalité matérielle
les blancs ont un pion pas s'éloigner le
pion à à gauche
oui un de l'échiquier et faut créer un
pion passer l'idée c'est de les grandes
règles dans les finales de pioncer
l'activité du roi oui et la création
d'un clan passé c'est deux éléments très
importants et d
on va pas donner d'ordres je voulais
donner dans cet ordre là il faut
évidemment combiner ces deux choses oui
il faut combiner deux choses
moi je pense je donnerai plus tôt la
priorité à l'avancé du roi mais bon
c'est un avis personnel je pense qu'il
faut toujours amené le roi au plus vite
en tout cas le réflexe en finale s'est
amené le roi vers le centre ici on a
déjà notre récente dans le pays son
départ donc deuxième réflexe ont créé un
pion passer au plus vite
on joue donc 1,5 il prend on reprend il
revient là petit truc
petite astuce l'on voit que le roi noir
est très bien placé il est sur sa
meilleure case ans et 6 ans gagne donc
un temps un jour roi b4 on le force à
bouger à ce délogée de cette case evian
17 ans gagne du terrain
trois des cinq bons à cette rousse et 6
et là comme d'habitude toutes les
conclusions vont avec les mêmes on va
prendre l'option sur la colonne c est
pendant que les noirs le prendront sur
la colonne la plus éloignée la colonne
pas et donc on aura gagné cette finale
puisque on sera plus proche de la
dernière se blesse qui est donc le pion
g5 1 qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un bilan
tout écouter avec parce qu'on est
passionné par les échecs non ce qu'il
faut c'est il faut vraiment faire donc
en finale en répèt faut faire très
attention le bus et la promotion c'est
d'abord l'activité du roi effectivement
tout à l'heure je voulais déjà être faut
combiner les deux foot c'est d'abord
l'activité du roi qui va vous permettre
de rentrer dans la position création
d'un pion pas ses pions pas s'éloigner
et puis je crois qu'on nous fait si faut
dire envoie faut se dire au revoir
alors eloi bientôt et bien le prochain
est lundi prochain pour une nouvelle
leçon sur quel thème le thème de la
prochaine leçon sera l'opposition en
finale l'option ça sera une des
dernières sur les finales de pions donc
chassé droit et demie gagner du terrain
bref un autre thème très très important
des finales de pion à suivre dans des
gonades la leçon cherté les notes en
voix